foreign
comes from Bill in Arkansas I bank with
truest bank and they offer a Delta
SkyMiles reward debit card it has a 99
or less depending on spending annual fee
but you get one mile for every two
dollars spent on all purchases except
ATM withdrawals the rewards do not
expire my wife's family lives a few
States over and we are currently
inheriting a family business so we do
travel quite a bit is this worth it in
your opinion
oh boy I'm I'm fired up about this one
Christina
no bill it is not worth it even though
it's a debit card I am not paying to
have a debit card and you just laid out
here's here's the deal you pay 99 but
here's the blessing Christina you get
one mile for every two dollars spent
here's the thing yeah when it comes to
miles there is no indication of what one
mile even means and so Bill's in
Arkansas and so I did a little pre-show
math here to go from Little Rock to
Arkansas A Little Rock to Nashville
round trip in December
is 31 000 points
so if you're doing the math at home one
mile for every two dollars spent that
means 30 000 miles is sixty thousand
dollars worth of spending for one person
to go round trip from Little Rock to
Nashville and back ouch
so you're going to pay a hundred dollars
for the annual fee then spend sixty
thousand dollars of your net income on
God knows what to go from Little Rock to
Nashville and back that same flight if
you just paid for it on the same airline
Delta would cost 282 dollars wow enjoy
your miles bill
so no never let rewards Drive decisions
right well and like what does that do to
the psyche to make you one want to make
sure you spent enough to make your 99
dollar fee worth it but then thinking
man I really want to get enough points
to get this flight so sixty thousand
dollars is the bar I have to reach I
feel like that encourages spending oh
absolutely and then you feel like you
won we go hey we got a free flight so
Christina I don't understand what the
issue is yeah but you spent sixty
thousand dollars to get it oh and so
your math is broken here uh so no never
do that and it's one of the reasons
Christina we launched our very own debit
card called gazelle uh the other day and
one of the reasons is we're sick of
banks screwing people over and so we
don't fee you to death there's no annual
fee there's no we don't even do
overdraft because we're like we don't
want you to spend money you don't have
it will just decline
and so it's a great way to spend and
save the Ramsay way if you want to check
that out but Bill I'm not falling for
this uh Sky Miles rewards debit card man
just do a budget save up for your
vacations pay for the flights do your I
like to use Google flights and
Skyscanner and all kinds of online tools
to just find the best deal on a flight
instead of being beholden to one Airline
right that's what I was going to say is
this is just through Delta like if you
look around at some of the cheaper
Airlines there's a good chance you could
find a flight for a hundred bucks
anyways you know Little Rock to
Nashville is not Far We've driven that
several times so one you could drive if
you really want to go but at the same
time like just shop around we both love
travel we both love travel deals we're
kind of obsessed with Skyscanner and
finding the best flight and it's like
you can do this in a much smarter way
yes so uh don't fall for this folks if
you're seeing these rewards and you see
well it's a debit card so that's helpful
but oh wait there's an annual fee and so
now I have to spend enough to at least
cover the annual fee which is going to
cause me to spend enough to cover the
annual fee and so it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy here that will cause you to be
broke so Bill I hope you say no to this
debit card and just stick to a no fee
debit card and don't spend because of
the rewards thanks for the question
though it's a good discussion it's a
good discussion because it's very
tempting like when you see that and you
see miles and you see the potential of a
free flight like that's exciting and it
can kind of get you stirred up to where
you don't really want to look at the
math you're just excited to go somewhere
excited to you know get on an airplane
that seems very cool and it's like wait
a minute when you break this down it's
not really as cool as this it's never
worth it and Christina we did an entire
episode on the fine print about this
very topic it's about credit card
rewards but now that debit cards are
starting to try to compete in this weird
space we have to watch out for this as
well so you can go listen to it it's
episode two of the fine print podcast
wherever you listen to podcast called
the true cost of credit card rewards and
I talked to an ex-employee of Capital
One whoa who dishes is and she explains
how they do tens of thousands of
experiments every year on consumers to
get them to spend more and instead of
cash back they went hey what if we did
like points and Miles because that's
confusing and they can you could be a
hundred thousand points and you feel
like you're winning but really uh you're
a loser so I'll fall for this don't fall
you're just a rat in the Maze and you
get to the cheese and you think you won
Until you realize oh my gosh I'm in a
maze I'm in a tiny prison
gosh that's so sad I know studying us
like rats we made Christina sad thanks
credit card companies